you're playing a very dark role in this
in front of the family well yeah dark
show yeah for sure absolutely yeah
that's not an I've heard I've heard of
this story and I just wanted to mention
it quickly because it's a story that I
found absolutely insane and impossible
and it's true yeah it's completely
insane and it is 100 true but yeah it
would there was a there was a
documentary uh about uh this family that
was on Netflix a few years ago called
abducted in plain sight but it's it's
the show is about the broberg family
whose daughter was kidnapped twice by a
very close family friend by a friend of
the family who's hung out with them and
spent a lot of time with them yeah and
and he was a master manipulator
blackmailer and and pedophile and he he
he he groomed not only the the the the
daughter but both of the parents
separately yes and blackmailed them and
it's an unbelievable story and you're
the father I I play the father of of I
played Bob roberg the father of Jan
broberg who was abducted and who was
playing Jake Lacy Jake Lacy okay who is
that is a dark role yeah yeah it's it's
really heavy stuff it was really really
dark stuff there are so many times it
happens 15 times a day where I say
that's why I'm not an actor
seriously I'm just always Blown Away by
people that can that can inhabit a role
like that and uh and and
explore that kind of Darkness or or just
you could play a serial killer yeah yeah
well because that I know you've got the
look got the beady eyes you've got it no
I I look I've killed and I'll kill again
so that's something I know but but
there's so many times where I see I I'm
not one of those people who thinks
acting that looks easy I've I've I'm
totally in awe of actors because I think
I don't have that I don't have that
thing I don't know how people do that I
mean this actually sort of goes into
what we were talking about earlier like
I I would much rather keep things light
and easy and and fun and so like if
there's a comedy to be had like all in
can't wait like sign me up because I
just want to be able to laugh as much as
humanly possible throughout the course
of the day but like this this thing was
so dark I mean it's hands down the most
like
a challenging thing that I've ever been
a part of sure and like I mean my head
is shaved I'm wearing glass like I did
everything I could to not look like
myself just because I was so intimidated
by what it was that we were trying to do
but I really took it as like a mission
to go like okay this is gonna be hard
this is going to be challenging and
difficult and they're going to be a lot
of days where you're not going to want
to go to work and there's going to be a
lot of days where you go get me the [ __ ]
home as soon as possible but I really
tried to do everything I could to go
that's make believe because I always say
look my job is to wear make believe and
pretend to be other people so I'm going
to wear make believe I'm going to
pretend to be Bob broberg for the day
and then when that camera is not on we
are trying to keep things light and and
and accessible and easy so that this is
not a miserable place to work every
single day it helped that we had kids
around so that we actually had to do
that in order like to sort of shelter
them but like I I mean I we had this
like actors
um holding area where it's just the you
know when they're setting up shots they
got to put the actors somewhere so they
can't just throw us into a room and lock
Us in it so they they call it actors
holding you know although there's not a
fence
they could some actors can't pick a lock
to save their lives and some some some
of us should should be locked up
um but uh like we all of a sudden I just
felt the urge to just have something
else to do on set that was just silly
and creative so we just started
designing like a fake Tiki Bar
within our actors holding and so I got
mirror balls and Christmas lights and I
was telling the kids like bring whatever
you want like everything goes up on the
wall like anything we can do so that
when we are on the stages it's a fun
environment a fun place to be I had an
11 hour playlist of tiki music and
Hawaiian music I can forward it to you
if you want
um and then we could okay all right all
right sorry no it turns out sorry Tiki
music turns out he's very very picky
when it comes to his music noted okay
excited no
um
but we had like I just put everything I
could to make it look like a Cheesy fun
environment and so that when we were on
the stages that was where we were
hanging and then when we went actually
onto the set that was where we would do
our work and then we would get the hell
out of there as soon as possible and and
that ended up thankfully being kind of
the way everyone like wanted to work as
well like and and it made that
experience so much better and I think it
made it possible for me to do all the
really dark stuff that I that I had to
do
um so it was yeah blast to make I don't
know what it's going to be like to watch
enjoy nine hours
nine hours of how the hell did this
happen yeah why why why well we'll show
you for the next 50 minutes